and you write at the library I mean is
that is that generally where you yeah
you're not distracted well maybe you're
inspired it makes I think when I moved
to Los Angeles I did find like I missed
I moved here from Barcelona Spain and
from Scotland and like something in
Europe we have a lot of street life and
so it's like different kinds of people
around us all the time and Los Angeles
can feel like a little bit like you're
in a bubble and sort of separate from
people that everyone's in their car and
then you go to places we see other
people they're kind of like you and you
know and something that I love about the
library here besides the fact it's just
beautiful and I always love light of
love libraries all my life when I was a
child I wanted to be a librarian so I
think like I just feel very at home in
them and I love the fact here though
that there's different kinds of people
and there's different kinds of stories
all around you and I love that like when
I'm writing I'll be totally focused but
then I just sort of you know you then
you can get up and look at some books
and read some poetry and and watch
people engage and in the library there's
like really really interesting people
there's all walks of life and I love
that I thrive on that and I think you
know if you're a storyteller and I'm
sort of observer of human see it's a
good place to be
you